[Musique]
ce lundi 18 juillet sous 36 degrés les
sportifs de l'île de loisirs de 50 ans
neeve et ont déserté les terrains de
volley ball pour l'ombre des arbres
direction l'accrobranche pour des
dizaines de jeunes commandé dans la
forêt c'est sûr qu'il fait plus froid
que si cet
autre part ça va moi je me suis bien
amusé ici ya des coins comme bon comme
ça après on peut se reposer et reprendre
des forces
si certains ont trouvé refuge à l'ombre
d'autres ont pris d'assaut l'immense
plan d'eau du site ici les canaux et
paddle ou encore voilier trouvent
facilement preneurs depuis le début de
la vague de chaleur l'occasion de se
rafraîchir habana tatar a dit mais par
contre voilà on autorise qui tombent
dans l'eau et qui seraient rapprochés
sera en tout cas le recommande elles
voient ils ont bien droit tu as envie la
chaleur c'est presque essentiel pour
certains au contraire pas question de
faire du sport sous ces fortes chaleurs
un banc à l'ombre à proximité de l'eau
suffit à leur plaisir hier j'ai vu sur
la météo qu'aujourd'hui va faire
vraiment chaud aujourd'hui et demain de
façon bine bine jusqu'où je suis pas je
connais pas le l'endroit est très bien
mais je regrette j'ai regardé sur maps
j'ai trouvé cela qu ici je me suis venu
pour pour un peu prendre de l'air le
site saint quentinois propose également
des jeux d'eau principalement destiné
aux enfants qui sont ouverts du mardi au
dimanche à partir de 13h30 cette vague
de chaleur devrait se poursuivre au
minimum jusqu'à ce mardi 19 juillet dans
les yvelines